2023 has been a year of sold out stadium concerts, but only one of the women breaking attendance
records has built a global brand singing upside down. High flying stunts are only part of
her appeal. Alicia Moore is known as much for her party anthems as her powerhouse voice.
And if the name is unfamiliar, it's because she's best known by her one word professional
identity. Pink. Pink famously has no filter. And fans who have followed her 25-year career
have come to expect her to share every detail of her sometimes troubled story.
The story will continue in a moment.
Do I have this right? You're willing to talk about anything? Any question is fine. There's
no offense taken. Yeah, it's all I'm open to all of it. A lot of people in your world
thrive on protecting privacy. You're an open book. Why? I guess I look at it in a very
specific way. If I'm a mystery to you, how can I expect you to connect with me? And if
I'm a person that's desperate for connection, then why would mystery be interesting to me?
I want to know you. I want you to know me. All right. Start by coming to one of her concerts.
We were there for her homecoming shows in Philadelphia last month. One stop on a year
and a half long tour. She's already set attendance records and stadiums around the world.
And sold more than $350 million in tickets. A pink concert is part rock ranger.
Part Broadway spectacle. With some tinkerbell sprinkled in. She belts out her hits while flipping
and flying 100 feet in the air. And she does it without lip syncing. When she says she
actually sings better upside down, believe her. Now 44, when she looks out into the crowd,
she sees a lot more moms and dads. She calls herself and her fans the uncool kids and takes
great pleasure in taking on their haters. Whether in her shows or on social media, her messages
don't mess with them or me. This image that you've created, you've got this famous snarl.
Yeah, right. I wonder if when that started, the message was, this is a woman that you don't
want to mess with. Well, this is a woman you don't want to mess with is a true statement.
I know what certain people think of when they look at me down to the fact that I'm muscular,
I'm outspoken and I have short hair. I'm possibly a dude, definitely a lesbian. People sort
of put you in a box no matter what you look like. Then my box happens to be if you're outspoken
and you don't sort of bend to societal norms, then you're scary and dangerous.
And the reality is, the reality is I am the goofiest, most fun, loving person that will
possibly kick your ass if I have to. These days, life is less, get the party started and
more get these kids to bed. Her six year old son, Jamison and 12 year old daughter, Willow,
are often on tour with her, writing their scooters on stage during sound checks. For
the hometown show in Philly, Pink's husband, Motocross star, Carrie Hart was there and
so was her mom, Judy. This is our tour library backstage. There's a library where the team
swaps books. Pink has a romantic novel she needs to return. We have a little sign in
she you actually have a sign in your side. I have a thing, but we don't have that. So
I've been backstage for other artists and some of the things I've seen are a lot of
booze. Yeah, a lot of party. Cool. My dresser, I'm used to be like whiskey and cigarettes,
then it was ball pits and stuffed animals. When she's not on the road, she's home in Southern
California. This is where she's Alicia Moore, a Mohawk wearing mom who baked sourdough and
is part of the PTA. She's either driving for school drop off or driving a forklift
on her 25 acre vineyard. She says she schooled herself on the science of wine making by studying
late into the night after her shows. So do I have this correct? You don't make pink rosé.
I do not make pink rosé. My grandash is it looks like a white wine. Occasionally it's
a bit peach, but you drink it. I drink a lot. Well, biggie smalls once said never get
high on your own supply. But you started I do make a lot of wine. Home is also where she
makes music. It's my music room. It's really great. Yeah, she's a writer on most of her songs
and says no topic is off limits. Not even the ups and downs in her marriage. And you
taught yourself to play on this sort of kind of I mean, I can play haves of songs. One
of my favorite songs is Make You Feel My Love. And I played this every day during COVID.
This is a Bob Dylan song made most recently famous by Adele.
That's one of my favorite songs.
When the rain is blowing in your face. And the world is on your case. I could offer you
woman brains to make you feel my love. I played that every day. Wow. Until I was good enough to go on stage and play an instrument.
She grew up singing opera and gospel in Doyle's town, Pennsylvania. But she says tension at home made her desperate to leave.
She calls her relationship with her father Jim Moore complicated. He served in Vietnam and passed away two years ago.
As a teen arguments with her mother were so bad, pink says one fight got physical and her mom fell down stairs.
She now calls that her one regret in life. You said you were the kid that other moms didn't want their kids to play with.
Why? I was a punk. I had a mouth. I was I had a chip on my shoulder. Basically I grew up in a house where every day
my parents were screaming at each other throwing things, hated each other. And then I got into drugs.
I was selling drugs. And then I was kicked out of the house. I dropped out of high school. That was off the rails.
What happened on Thanksgiving in 1995?
Thanksgiving of 1995. I was at a rave and I overdosed. I was on...
Oh boy. Ecstasy, angel dust, crystal, all kinds of things. And then I was out done too much.
You know what I'm saying? Yeah.
She says that was the end of hard drugs for her. And weeks later got her first record deal as the lead singer
in an R&B girl group. But they didn't last long.
So when you're starting out, the industry sort of seems like they've got you going down a path.
They paint you with an R&B brush. Yes, I signed to LaFace Records. We were the token white girls on a black label.
I was told to take etiquette classes very early on. They wanted me to learn how to wear dresses and use the right fork.
How that work out? I went once, but it didn't work.
What did they not like? I think they were trying to turn me into something that I didn't want to be.
Images everything in this business.
Using her teenage nickname Pink, she went solo and her first album was an R&B double platinum success.
She then broadened her sound to include rock and pop.
And not so subtly named her next album, Miss Unda Stood.
So you better get the song out.
How?
It was a career defining hit, selling 15 million copies around the world.
You'd said in the past it felt like you were never winning the popularity contest among your peers.
What do you mean by that?
We've sold 3 million tickets in the last six months, but you don't really hear about it unless you
went. So at the end of the day, do I give a s***? Who talks about me?
As long as the mom and the daughter or the dad who's in the pink t-shirt,
as well as his daughter and her three friends had a fantastic time,
or the gay couple that came together and felt super safe at my show because no one heckled them.
That's what really matters.
And then there's this.
We wanted to know how she does it, singing upside down as an asthmatic no less.
Well, it took a lot of childhood gymnastics classes and tortured training sessions with her
aerialist coach, Dre O'Lebar.
Okay, tighten up your stomach.
Okay, ready?
Be nice.
Not sink.
Homeowner.
Just because it powers us and me gonna die, you gotta get a walk.
I'm not just a singer, I'm a gymnast. I can do all kinds of things.
I'm physical. This body, like, there's the muscles that scare people, it's my power.
Right? It's like, I don't eat well to look good.
I eat well to go far, fast and hard.
At 5'3", she is all muscle and make no mistake as tough as she looks.
I realize that the machete that I've always carried, this metaphorical machete that I've
always carried that made me a really difficult kid is what makes me really good at what I did today.
And it makes me a survivor.
Do you feel like you needed that hard edge, that machete to climb as far as you've climbed in this
business? Absolutely. Absolutely. I never got a record deal because I was cute.
I got a record deal because I was fiery. I had a lot to say and I had a voice.
So, I'm relieved I don't have to fall back on sort of conventional beauty and
that doesn't have to be my thing and I don't have to keep that up either as I age. I don't have to be that.
I can be all of this. She won't need a plan be anytime soon, but as she told us at midnight over a
glass of wine in her dressing room in Philadelphia, she is planning the next chapter.
It's what any self-respecting acrobatic, sequin loving entertainer would do, a Las Vegas residency.
I would like to have the best show that Vegas has ever seen and I think that I can.
For a performer like me to have a stage that doesn't have to travel.
Oh my god, you can do so much. So all these years in, what's the hardest part about your job now?
I guess that I keep demanding more and more and more and more from myself physically, emotionally,
spiritually, vocally. I want to raise the bar all the time and I'm sort of going against time,
right? How do you keep out doing that? I like going against societal norms when they say a woman has to
slow down, become smaller, take up less space, calm down. No, absolutely not. Why? Who says,
why can't we ride it till the wheels fall off? It's not a plan I'm doing.
Go backstage with pink after a concert. Come on, get it. At 60 minutes overtime.com.